[Music]
foreign
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the Guardians
political editor pipakura and the
telegraphs associate editor for politics
Christopher hope welcome to both of you
so to the front pages then let's kick
off with the times the new submarine
cooperation deal between America the UK
and Australia is the lead for the Times
which says Rishi sunak has done the deal
to protect the world against emerging
threats in the decade ahead
the Metro says that despite the apparent
resolution of the agreement or
disagreement rather between Gary lineker
and the BBC there are still calls for
the corporation's chairman Richard Sharp
to resign
the eye has the headline pressure grows
on BBC bosses over linica climbed down
the guardian two focusing on that angle
of the story BBC bosses facing pressure
they say Daily Mail believes that
lineker escaping any form of punishment
is an insult to license payers
well the express goes one step further
suggesting the controversy could mean
the end of the license fee altogether
here's the Stars analysis of that story
one nil to the crisp salesman the
telegraph meanwhile looks ahead to the
budget on Wednesday suggesting the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt intends to raise
the tax-free allowance for pensions by
more than half a million pounds the sun
reports that the former pop star Gary
Glitter has been put back in prison for
breaching the conditions of his license
and that is also the lead story for
tomorrow's Daily Mirror
while the international edition of the
Ft has more on the Fallout from the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you listen
to our guests so let's head straight to
Pippa and Christopher plenty of coverage
of uh of Gary lineker obviously which
we'll come to but Christopher kickoff
festival with the Delhi Telegraph if you
can looking ahead to the budget now
everyone holding their breath waiting to
see what's going to come up but we've
heard from Jeremy Hunt suggesting that
he's peeling away the layers that stop
people working one of which is pensions
we've seen it in the medical profession
with Consultants departing the NHS so
what is the plan as outlined in the
telegraph
well the plan here is to lift the
maximum you can save in a pension maybe
as much as 1.8 million pounds it's
called the lifetime allowance the LTA
and this is called the so-called
doctor's tax it's a big concern in why
tool why do so many consultants leave
the NHS so so soon
um for a quieter life maybe in the
private sector or even not working at
all because
um they they get they they get capped so
much and get taxed so much when they put
money into their pension above a certain
level it's a big picture this I think
for the trussites there's a group a
growth group uh the conservative growth
group uh which has been pushing for this
and met with Jeremy Hunt just last week
about it I think this is um a sop to to
the right of the party who I think
should be disappointed in Wednesday's
budget I should say this is the first
time we've had a proper budget front
page story
um for a few days we thought we'd be
starting these these stories going back
into the weekend but Gary lineker this
crisp salesman got in the way
it's a one million pound
pot farmer as well you said about not
working but some have gone to the
pharmaceutical industry
um you know for them there was a
disincentive to work and it's removing
the disincentives which is where Jeremy
Hunt's Focus has been and the focus two
of the work and pensions secretary
pepper
yes I mean much of the focus has been
obviously on growth and we're key
impediment to that has been the number
of people in the workforce
um and uh as as Chris says as a
telegraph exemplifies there a lot of the
focus has been get on getting people uh
pursuing people not to retire so early
or indeed to come back from retirement
off the golf course we've heard a lot of
references to various speeches for
ministers but actually a much more
significant issue is the rising number
of long-term sick people often long-term
sake there are actually fewer early
retirees today than there were before
the pandemic
um but but people
um on off on long-term sick has risen by
more than 350 000 since the start of the
pandemic uh which accounts for more than
half of the growth and inactivity in
that period so
um there's a there's a big there's a big
problem there as well and of course um
Mills tried the working pension
secretaries has been carrying out a
review which you're expecting to hear
more from more of
um around the time of the budget on
Wednesday uh looking at different ways
to help encourage people back into the
workforce but of course it's broader
than that because many of those who are
often long-term sick are men over 50 I
mean that's specifically is obviously
other people as well but that's a large
a large chunk of disproportionate number
of them and half of those
um are off with um it's not just
physical elements it's also mental
health uh mental health issues and the
support as we've seen particularly for
mental health provision has been paired
right back uh the services been
obviously under a lot of pressure coming
out of the pandemic but uh but
nevertheless Services have been paired
back and until you sort of you deal with
the uh the support that people are
getting through the NHS and the and the
the health system it's very difficult to
to sort of you know re-jig the work and
pension system uh to encourage them to
incentivize them to come back more the
two things have to go hand in hand so
expect we'll hear a bit more from that
on Wednesday from Jeremy Hunt as well
yes and the telegraph pointing out um
Christopher that Mr Hunt's budget will
be delivered against a bank drop of a
banking industry in crisis the bank of
England the suggestion is is expected to
raise interest rates one more time to
4.25 from a level of four percent
suggesting in America perhaps that
interest rates might slow because of the
banking issues there
um but what else can we expect to hear
in terms of how the economy is doing
um and what other issues might we expect
to look out for on Wednesday
well so far Jeremy Hunt has done what he
said he'd do he forecasts a shallow
um maybe not a recession he's got away
with not having a recession so far which
is some victory from where we were back
in November with that emergency
emergency Autumn statement you brought
in after the list trust uh quasi-coatang
at a debacle
um what the big pressure right now is to
not go ahead with this increase in
corporation tax to 25 next month or only
one tabloid newspaper is started a
countdown clock 20 days to catastrophe
at the weekend and that's where the
pressure will be on Jeremy Hunt he had a
good day today he sold out the um the
Silicon Valley Bank who will sell for a
pound to HSBC with none of our money no
no tax money going to it in the UK at
least but I think things will get harder
and harder through the week the right of
the party I know will not accept him
going ahead with this increase in
corporation tax but all the guidances
they're going to go ahead with it
they've got about nine billion of
Headroom to play play with and that's it
so I think he's going to let them down
he'll tweak at the edges on allowances
um what he might call the kind of
effective tact uh
um corporation tax because of the
reliefs he can bring in but I think he
won't be enough and that's the problem
he's got but we are waiting for the
so-called rabbit the lawsonian rabbit
out the Hat we're not sure what it is
quite yet yeah I thought this trust
killed off the rabbits but anyway
of my corporation tax um there's going
to be an alcohol tax rate according to
your paper as well 45p extra on a bottle
of wine a new system for taxing alcohol
coming into effect with stronger drinks
to have higher duties so that would mean
90 of still wines would see an increase
in the amount that people have to pay uh
come later this summer to the guardian
now your paper Pippa and your name on
the story in fact
um the Gary lineker Fallout and where
it's left BBC bosses what are you saying
yeah well of course this all follows the
story we've heard so much about over the
last few days which culminated today
with the BBC issuing
um an apology for the disruption to
sport scheduling over the weekend uh the
news that Gary lineker would be
returning which he welcomed to match the
day uh this weekend coming uh and that
the BBC is going to conduct a review of
social media guidelines for its stars
but ultimately it's the BBC which comes
out of this looking as one Observer as
well as ever said Gary lineker won BBC
credibility zero
um they haven't handled this situation
well at all right from the start uh they
there's a suggestion that the feeling
that they've been on the defensive uh
obviously the BBC is in a position where
it's dealing more broadly with an
existential crisis because there are
those in government and certainly those
on the conservative back benches that
want to rip up their their funding uh
systems the the license BBC license fee
and replace it with another model that
they argue is is more appropriate to the
way that people consume their media
their media these days but
um ultimately this this was about uh
There You Go pictures of Gary lineker uh
being welcomed and stuff he's taken with
him but um this was about some comments
that he made about the government's
small boats policy about some of the
language that ministers had used uh uh
but that's how it started but it
spiraled into a much bigger issue for uh
for the BBC and about its credibility
that's impartiality and today what's
happened is that the spotlight has has
shifted firmly onto Tim Davey the
director General and specifically to
Richard Sharp the BBC chair who has
stayed silent throughout this whole Saga
um but who's already under investigation
by the appointments Watchdog after it
emerged that he helped facilitate a loan
agreement for Boris Johnson when he was
prime minister just weeks before he was
then recommended by Boris Johnson to
take on the role of BBC chair and the
suggestion is that he didn't declare
this as he may have as he should have
done at the time now if that if that
conclusion the appointments Watchdog
concludes that that is the case then
he's in he's really in a in a pretty
difficult position as Kirsten said
um this morning an untenable position
and it's really interesting to note that
Rishi sinek and Jeremy Hunt when they've
been asked about him and whether they
support Richard Sharp who was in fact a
former boss of Rishi cynics back in the
day at Goldman Sachs and then an advisor
at the treasury
um whether he's backed him they've
declined to do so and number 10 today
was uh suggesting that actually we'd
have to wait until that appointment to
Watchdog report came out I mean that is
not exactly a ringing endorsement or uh
you know huge backing for somebody who's
already
in the spotlight for all the reasons
that he might not want to be and I think
it raises questions going forward as if
that if that inquiry comes back and is
is really damning of him it doesn't
sound particularly like the government's
going to be willing to LEAP into his
support
um so I think his his career certainly
uh it still hangs in the balance tonight
yes the Metro is certainly featuring uh
Richard time for a Sharp exit uh calls
for the BBC Chief to go over the lineker
Fiasco Tory Fury grows that the
presenter is still in his job uh
beleaguered BBC chairman Richard Sharp a
former Tory donor as the paper points
out was accused of going missing in
action so the questions continue
um Christopher to your paper and your
name on it
um lineker has shown he's bigger than
the BBC tell us more about your argument
yeah these are comments here I think
what's interesting how is how this
debate's run since mid last week and now
finally we've got some agreement I think
on it's basically been a massive BBC
up until until today
um it was a big debate about whether the
Nick was right to compare language
around this small boats policy to Nazi
Germany some said yes some say no became
a freedom of speech issue but suddenly
it's all coalist coalescing a bit of BBC
bashing which uh um Fleet streets it
seems to be enjoy doing sometimes oh
across the left and right newspapers and
the guardian the telegraph mail broadly
similar
um yeah these quotes here in the story
that we've written today come from
um this new Deputy chairman of the toy
Parton Lee Anderson uh concerned about
uh Gary lineker and the way he's he
really has difficult on the nose of the
BBC and it has to be very easy for them
I do I disagree a bit with Pippa on the
Richard Sharp issue
um I I don't see what he could have done
having looked at the story a bit more
close a bit closely he essentially was
um he came across this a guy who want to
give money a loan money to Boris Johnson
told Simon case about it and then tried
to recuse himself in the conversation
um he maybe should have told MPS about
it when he's appointed but otherwise I
can't see what he did and what's
interesting about the story I think is
the fact that as I understand it uh Mr
Sharp has not yet been contacted by this
inquiry we're five weeks into it
starting that for me says that the the
Canon offices is quite Keen to park in
the very long grass even the elephant
grass maybe so it can't be seen for a
while and hoping this might die away but
with kirst armor today putting the
pressure on to Mr Sharp it shows it
won't go very far but we've had this
debate going back to Gavin Davis 21
years ago he was made chair of the of
the of the BBC the toys went bananas
he's a former labor donor Etc it goes
around in circles as we get older I'm
afraid yeah the elephant
that's a new one for me for me I might
add that to my hair
comments and uh just very quickly let's
see the daily mail
um you know one of those papers as you
said you've been hot on this from the
very beginning a slap in the face for
BBC license pairs as the Director
General caves in and says sorry the
knicker keeps his job and Carries On
tweeting um you know in one sentence
Peppa the mail has made it quite clear
uh what side of the fence they stand on
yes and it's not just about Gary lineker
it's also about BBC bashing and they've
been bashing the BBC throughout on this
one yeah
you might say for decades in fact in
some areas but there we are okay lots
more stuff to come uh including the
historic defense agreement between
Britain the US and Australia that live
news conference in San Diego earlier
we'll get uh into that after the break
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me once again Pippa
creara and Christopher Hope from the
guardian and the telegraph uh Pippa
let's go to the time shall we uh the
Fanfare in San Diego tonight with the
leaders of Australia the UK and the
United States and a massive building
program for nuclear-powered submarines
underway
um to keep security effectively in the
indo-pacific
um and effectively this is aimed at the
the threat of China is it not
yeah I mean this has been a deal which
has been in the offing for for some
months now I mean you'll cast your your
mind back to last year when the French
got totally upset that uh Australia the
US and the UK were reaching some sort of
trilateral agreement uh on defense and
and they felt that they were being cut
out of it it caused a diplomatic
incident at the time which um Joe Biden
had smooth over with with Emmanuel
macron and this is a combination of
these months of talks these three men
used to do videos appearing in San Diego
in California together and to strike a
deal uh to build a multi-billion pound
Fleet of submarines in Britain using U.S
technology that's also being shared with
Australia although I don't think we're
going to see more Australian Australia
getting nuclear subs
um because or in the uh is that right I
might ever got that right yes that I
think they will they will train the
Brazilian Navy to operate nuclear subs
and will deploy a UK submarine to
Western Australia from 2027 but they
wouldn't have um Australian nuclear subs
because obviously
um that would be seen as a as a very
sort of hostile act by China in that in
the indo-pacific in the indo-pacific
region but it is definitely a result
um for Britain because uh this this
Fleet is going to be built in the UK and
potentially we're seeing a doubling of
Britain's submarine Fleet which
currently
um is is seven Vanguard uh submarines
carrying the Trident missile system the
suggestion is that it could potentially
uh more than double
um in the decades ahead and vicious that
says that this is because of a difficult
and dangerous decade ahead we've already
seen a sort of a shift in
um in in the the geopolitical landscape
with Russia invading Ukraine with China
uh being appearing less willing
um to uh also rather be more willing to
sort of if not overtly support Russia at
least
um there's been some suggestion that
they might at some point provide weapons
um their involvement in in that conflict
obviously would be be very difficult for
the region some manage and we saw the we
saw the Strategic review the latest
tweaks the Strategic review coming out
today as well in which um Rishi sinak
makes clear and then perhaps not the
strongest some of his back benches might
like that China is of course the um the
sort of growing threat in the future
that they want to that they want to sort
of watch out for so
um this is all about
um an alliance between nations which
have obviously a long a long military
history shared military history together
and uh which obviously share very
similar values going forward
um and like you say the fact that it's
based on the west coast it was announced
on San Diego the west coast of the
United States
um on the you know overlooking the
Pacific Ocean
um was a real sort of indication that
that is where these these two nations in
this particular Alliance uh think that
the threat of the future will lie